well things aren't so happy in
Washington DC faces new uncertainty this
morning over a potential government
shutdown and the sudden resignation
announcement of a well-respected cabinet
member
defense secretary Jim mattis said he
will step down after president Trump's
stunned advisors with this week's
decision to pull US troops out of Syria
sources tell CBS News the president is
also ordinate ordering 7,000 troops to
leave Afghanistan that position mattis
also opposes the retired Marine general
wrote in his resignation letter you have
the right to have a Secretary of Defense
whose views are better aligned with
yours Republican Senator Marco Rubio
tweeted that the letter shows quote we
are headed towards a series of grave
policy errors which will endanger our
nation and empower our adversaries David
Martin is at the Pentagon David good
morning good morning secretary mattis
delivered this letter personally to the
president yesterday afternoon in it he
says the US must remain clear-eyed about
countries like Russia China and North
Korea but his most profound disagreement
with the president is over the treatment
of American allies he and the president
have a good relationship but sometimes
they disagree last night White House
press secretary Sarah Sanders tried to
downplay the differences between
secretary mattis and the president while
lawmakers from both parties voiced
concerns and criticism about Madison's
resignation our troops look to secretary
mattis as a leader and now he is going
to be leaving them sir this is very
serious for our country
Republican Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell wrote he was distressed by
Madison's departure saying the US must
maintain a clear-eyed understanding of
our friends and foes and recognized that
nations like Russia are among the latter
from the start President Trump was a
difficult boss to work with when he
announced his travel ban on mostly
Muslim countries it was the first
Mathers had heard of it he also didn't
know mr. Trump would tweet that
transgender service members would no
longer be allowed to serve in uniform
the final straw was the president's
decision to pull US troops out of Syria
they're coming back now we won and
that's the way we want it
NATO's hard power in a defense of Oregon
orientation is our ticket to peace the
fundamental disagreement was over as
mattis put it in his letter my views on
treating allies with respect what we're
doing with NATO where for many years
they're not paying their bills mr. Trump
has consistently lambasted NATO members
for not spending enough on defense
former defense secretary William Cohan
for secretary mattis who's never been
known to quit anything every star that
he has on his shoulders was earned in
the blood and the mud a battle and that
has to be taken into account when he
says we are betraying our allies under
these circumstances in the letter mattis
says it has been a privilege to serve
his country he does not say it has been
a privilege to serve Donald Trump he
plans to step down On February 28th and
the White House hopes to name a
replacement before the end of this year
bianna it's quite a letter that he wrote
the president and I think of what
senator corker said last year where he
said Tillerson mattis and Kelly separate
our country from chaos all three are
either gone or plan to leave he said of
the time you should really worry if the
if the three of them leave if any of
them leave and now all three of them but
you know James Madison was this say to
you John well what was striking is the
scope of the letter this was not about a
specific dispute what secretary mattis
said two key things one you have to
partner with your allies and respect
them that's not just NATO that's all
allies and he said you have to be
clear-eyed about the threats Russia and
China those are the kinds of things that
undergird American national security
policy for the last 50 60 years and so
what he is saying is those fundamental
principles are at odds with president
Trump's view of the world and James
Madison and sober person and he said my
four decades of service that are
dedicated to those principles are at
odds with your presidency that is a
sweeping statement from some
who is not prone to saying things just
kind of off-the-cuff when it comes to
strategic strategic or the position of
the United States never seems good to
hear words like distressed and
distraught in reaction to a resignation
such as this and for your top advisers
to be stunned by this news well that's
also part of it is it's is it's hard to
know where things are going when there
are surprise moves like this and again
it goes back to the allies one of the
criticisms against President Obama is
that allies never knew where the US was
headed and and that's what part part of
the critique of President Trump that
James Madison is putting his finger on
is that this is unpredictable as well
our allies don't know where we're headed
and that creates instability no members
and our generals didn't know where the
president was headed came to Syria as
well until the president tweeted about
it